the stress is evident of working on the
front line of the corona virus outbreak
in America on Monday nurses outside a
hospital in New York protesting the lack
of face masks gowns and other personal
protective equipment available to them
New York's health care system is
cracking under heavy strain we don't
have the space that we need we don't
have the staff that we need there are
refrigerated trucks outside of my
hospital
New York's governor announced nearly 600
new deaths in the past 24 hours but said
the so called curve and new cases and
hospitalizations seems to maybe be
lessening with still no vaccine New York
hospitals have reverted to using an
anti-malaria drug as part of a treatment
and prevention program for 4,000
coronavirus patients despite there being
no widespread scientific evidence it
helps battle the virus I think it's
still too early to tell
I think we we are still looking at the
the data but right now we're willing to
try just about anything to save patients
other forms of help are arriving
military doctors treat coronavirus
patients at New York City's largest
Convention Center is been transformed
into a 2,500 bed militarized hospital
originally the Javits Convention Center
here behind me was supposed to be open
only for non coronavirus patients but as
the crisis deepened in New York City
health officials said they needed more
help and now this convention center is
open exclusively only to help those that
are infected with Coppa 19 while the
curve might be flattening there is no
sign this will be over anytime soon
on Monday the governor extended this
statewide shutdown until at least the
end of April Gabriel Sandow al Jazeera